you want to know the mistake that most
creators are making judging their
results after three videos judging their
results after 33 videos judging your
results after posting for a few weeks or
a few months or even a year Mr Beast was
posting for five years and you're like
judging yourself after five weeks and
getting all in your head and emotional
about things relax Rebecca
take a chill pill Paul like we gotta we
gotta take a step back like this stuff
takes time YouTube is a marathon and not
a Sprint
you know Gary vaynerchuk who today is
got an entirely different thing going on
had originally one show not 64 pieces of
content a day one show called Wine
Library TV this was like the full
resolution like what you see on screen
like that's like the high that was the
original resolution of the show it was
shot in like 480p on a camcorder he had
he was working at his dad's wine store
and liquor store and he started to make
a a live not live but like a one take
wine review show he went a thousand
episodes that was what brought him to
original popularity but then after that
he launched a new business vaynermedia
and didn't even post content for about
three years because he was doing
business operations hiring people
getting things going and so when you
look at someone's trajectory I feel like
he has like 10 million Instagram
followers or something now like you look
at him today I think he has 20 25 30
people just on his personal brand Team
and then he's got like 1300 in his other
company so again you're hearing people
like the the whatever internet Guru
recommend this or that tactic and I'm
not saying there's not value there I'm
saying the key is self-awareness for
what season you're in and when you're
applying the advice this is the miss
this this whole this keeps people small
it gets it keeps people discouraged and
it holds people back because when you're
imitating the actions of somebody that's
at year five or year seven in their
journey and you're on day seven you're
setting yourself up to be frustrated and
potentially also have the advice
backfire and not ultimately work two
things number one I've had too much
coffee today number two if you have not
seen our free master class yet you're
gonna love it if you're serious about
growing your YouTube channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class